Hey Will, hello there, hey Sean, we only got some real sweaty pits today. Are you concerned about anything or are you just nervous? I just took a lie detector. Oh wow, and what was the result? I'm a liar. Anyway, this episode is going to be great. Yeah, we're going to work out some truth. Yeah, it's an all new smart list.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Hot Mike. Hot mics. Hot mics.
Hi, hot mics. Hey, hi, hot mics. Um, hot mics. As soon as pixelable, your hot mics. Post-money page. I'd love to take a look at all your hot mics. Look at you. So tired. He's still. He's so tired.
He's still got it. He's so tired. It's so tired. Sean, you had a hot bob once, didn't you? I had a hot, you know, I had a hot totty, hot bob and a hot mic. You ever had a hot bob haircut?
Yeah, you did on the, what you'm gonna call it, Stooges Film. I had that shelf haircut in the 80s where you cut it. Of course. Did you really? Yeah, you buzzed. That sounds very to Pesh mode.
It's total. It's TDM total to Pesh. I had like, like, kind of long and then in short in the back. You know, you had it like covering one of your eyes. Yeah, just kind of like coming up, you know, Archie's kind of got that right? You're all just son there, listener. He's got, he's got a little bit of a, what's that?
Kind of looking through there. Yeah, well, now it's kind of long all around. What's that? Yeah. That's a, what's that haircut of looking through there. Now it's kind of long all around. What's that? That's what's that haircut? Yeah. Yeah. I can't hear you because my hair's blocking my eyes, not my ears.
It's a bit of an early, last thing he says to himself before he leaves, what's that? Yeah. Yeah. Our buddy Richard, the most incredible real estate broker in the world. He is so good. If you're looking to buy a home in Los Angeles area,
especially in the west side of Los Angeles area. Tricky Dickie, Rick Ehrlich. Richard Ehrlich is your guy. Yeah, amazing. And he's also an OG super fan of smart loss. Yes, so hello to Richard, if you're listening. I need your turn. Richard's got a, Richard's got, I've made a board you with this
before, he's got a mirror face like we all do, but he's got a, he's got a mirror face, like we all do. But he's got a, he's got a trigger sentence that launches that mirror face. You know, everyone's got a face that they use. Well, when you look in the mirror, when you want to look your best, like one last look to go out, you kind of tighten up the eyes and maybe turn your head a little bit. He had a right. Yeah, exactly. Right.. So what Richard does to prompt the mirror look he's looking for is he pretends that he is asking someone for directions, right? He's pulled up in his car and next to someone walking their dog, maybe, and he asked some directions and they give them the directions and he looks forward over steering wheel and
then he figures, well, man, we didn't hear it correctly. And he'll turn to his left to the person and he'll go, well, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man,
man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man,
man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man just say, that's the new one, right? Yeah, he never looks hotter than when he says it's where. Which is so crazy, because he's such a nice guy. He's a nice guy, he's nice look in.
But he's just, he's not good with directions. Sean, good morning. Good morning to you. What have you done so far today aside from putting on some smartless swag, I see there on your body? You know, he's always wearing smartless shit. Yeah. We're like, we're televising this and he's helping move merchandise.
I wear it because I really like it. Where I sleep in it. Hmm. He sleeps in it. Sean, what was the sleep schedule last night? Because you have a weird, you wake up in the night and then you go back to bed early in the morning. Yeah, I go to bed at midnight.
I get up at about 3 a.m. I stay up until about six or seven, then I fall back asleep for a couple hours and I'm good to go. And then I need like a 10 minute nap. And then I'm good to go. Total chaos and then I'm good to go. I know.
Oh, I know. Oh, what? Don't start doing will. It's total cash. How's it? How's it to email that three or four in the morning? I know. Oh, I know. Oh, I know. Oh, I Don't start doing will I love where your impression of me just has the dumbest look You know what we've done here Sean though. We've we've we've we've we've we boosted up young Willie Willie started this he started the pod a little bit down a little bit out of sorts Yeah, and then it's just a little bit of love.
And now the wings are flapping. All right, tighten up guests. Here we come today. We have a guest who's a giant in many categories. She's a Titan in music, acting, producing, philanthropy, business, and social media. If you wanted to describe a person who's uniquely suited to soar in today's media and cultural
systems, you would simply say her name. I think that's right. She's a Grammy, Emmy, SAG, Golden Globe, and Critics Choice Nominative Musician, actress and producer. Her music is amassed 34 billion streams globally. She's got a movie coming out, a scene show that's already on, and a company that exceeds 300 million in sales annually. And when she's not running those things, she's keeping up with her 428 million followers
on Instagram. What else needs to be said, guys? Please welcome the lazy, unaccompanied, unmotivated, and perpetually failing Miss Alina Gomez. Woohoo! Woohoo! Wow! Oh, boy. Wow. and perpetually failing Miss Alina Gomez. Woo-hoo! Woo-hoo! Wow. Oh, boy.
Wow. I love the unmotivated, perpetually failing. It was so hard not to laugh. It was so hard. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. Wow. Oh my gosh, Alina, hello.
Hi, guys. I'm so happy to be here. I'm so happy you're here. I'm so happy you're here. This is a very nice thing you're doing for us and our listeners. Oh, no. I'm just more more my thing. I'm so happy. No, it's pretty cool of you. If we didn't know, it looks like you were lying in bed and she's got, we have an overhand.
Oh, yes. Well, that is my beautiful background that I made for you guys, because I figured that would be better than... You're keeping a real listener. Listen, she's got just a sheet draped over just a bunch of dead bodies behind you. Yeah, perhaps. Good work. Thanks. Nice second. I'm murders. Oh, yeah.
Well, we're going to get to that. We're going to get to that. So, Selena, where do we find you this morning? Are you in Los Angeles? I am. I am home right now. And I just had my coffee. And, yep. What time do you usually get up every morning? I'm a 630 guy. I am home right now and I just had my coffee and yep. What time do you usually get up every morning?
I'm a 630 guy. I'm about 730. Are there animals to feed? Yes, I have two dogs. You do? What kind? They're little multi-pues. They're pretty annoying, but cute. To the same.
Is that because your body gets you up at 7 or you just lost your voice? No, my body does. I think I don't know. For some reason, maybe the show or something, it's just embedded in me or that I'm automatically up. And then I feel like a piece of shit if I wake up at like 10. Sure. Yeah.
Even though those are nice. What is that about the body that'll just wake you up at the same time every single day? Circadian rhythm. Circadian. We're rarveling at the body. Look at that. Yeah. And then if you just point it, and then if you point your eyes at something, it tells
your brain what you're seeing. Huh. It's just you're like a one man Spielberg movie. Just a wonder. Yeah. Guys, if you put this in front of another, you'll just end up moving forward. That's incredible. All right.
So, Celia, with these two dogs, they're multi-pues. Yes. So, that's a combo, right? That's a mix. Yes, they're very cute. They're brother and sister. No, they are. I got them at two different times, but they definitely don't act like brother and sister.
No. Rescue spear breads. We can cut that if you want. No, no, no, I actually, not afraid to say during COVID, I was very scared and lonely. And I found a one on Craigslist because the mom was like, we had babies that we don't know what to do. Yes, they're like, we don't know what to do.
Our dog had puppy, so I was like, I'll take one. Clear, they're like, we don't know what to do our dog head puppy. So I was like, I'll take one. Clear out for a joke. Go ahead, Will. No, no, no, no. No, it actually was really sketchy though. They like drove in from Vegas and like rolled the window halfway down and passed me the dog and wanted the cash. I was like, all right, my my my my
did have a bad experience. I did have a bad experience once. He's got a guy posted on Craigslist. He said, who wants for a hundred bucks, you want to come on. Check out these puppies. And let me say when I got to his house, it was not dogs. Dogs. I'm not dogs. Come check out these puppies for a hundred bucks.
Thank you, Will. Thank you. You rest again. All right. Let's. Will tell you what are your own mouth. We're a little sloppy this morning. Super slabby. Selena, isn't it better to get this over with than then afternoon? No, no, I actually don't mind this. This is a great way to start my day. You guys are making me laugh.
Well, keeping these bents, not over yet. We'll, we'll let you revisit that at the end to see if you still love it. All right. Now, Selena, you're incredibly accomplished. You started very young. I want to know. So you started with acting. Yes, because mom was an actor and got you kind of
interested in that. Yeah, she actually never pressured me or said that's what I should do. She just did a lot of theater growing up. So she never really did anything television-wise. And I was seven when I got my first job because I was only child super dramatic and I was like, I'm so capable of this. And I do. Kind of all it takes. Yeah, I really, but it worked and I've just been working every sense and I feel lucky. Was this Barney? That was Barney. That's crazy. You're starting with Barney. Yes. That's a pretty, right? The guy who played Barney, he was pretty hot.
Was he? Yeah, he was hot. He had to be like fit and like cute because he was wearing this like, he doesn't have to be dead, but he was. He was a Barney. Hot Barney. This is changing everything. He knew Doc.
So he was a plushie, yeah. Uh-huh. Oh, I'm sorry, Sean. Was that just quick for Tracy really quick? Just break it down. Tracy need to know this. Is she want to know what a plus she is? A bunch of these like a fetish where people dress up in like costumes and stuff, right? No, I heard you guess.
What do you mean, right? You don't need to say right question mark to us. Yeah. Like we're going to hear something or something or that is correct, Sean. All right. So we're with Barney and and we're having fun on that, and then, how did Barney happen? I really want to know. It was, yeah, it was like a little thing,
but I was in line with 1,400 people on a hot Texas day, and my mom was like, are you sure you want to do this? I was like, yeah, I'm fine. Because you knew what TV was, and you thought it'd be cool to me. Yeah, I mean, my mom wasn't very Intense about what I could watch so I would stay up and watch friends with her and Willing Grace and
That was like what I grew up with Barney and Willing The longest time by the way on my bio on Instagram says I love willing grace No way that's a sweet thing. Yeah, after like a solid year and then everyone was like, can you maybe change that? I was like, that's very sweet. Did you ever see the episode where, where, uh, uh, Will was in a dance-off with, uh, Sean and Jackson, with Janet Jackson? You did? I was a back, with Bill.
I played it back at dancer. Oh, that's right. And then Karen got mad because she fell for you. And yes, I get her. Oh, my God, you really are a fan. Wait. Well, I remember you snapping those moves. I think I was there that night, right? You really know how to finish a move. Remember how it really was hard point, but we're so tired. And Jimmy's like, okay, let's do it again. I looked at Sean. I'm like, I do it again. But, but Salina, do you know just as'm like, five six. But, but, Salina, do you know just as a, as a Will and Grace superfan, you know, that we,
there's a podcast that Sean does called Just Jack and Will that he does with Eric McCormack? No, I do know. I actually do know. And I remember like, my friends sent me the link because she knew that I was obsessed and I had no idea. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Sean, did you know that Salina Gomez was such a huge Will and Grace fan? I did because I'm really good friends with Marty Short. Oh, yes. And then we chatted on the phone, me and Selena chatted on the phone like a year ago or something, and you were like, oh my god.
And I was like, oh my god. I know I freaked out. And then I was like, oh my god. And she was like, no, likewise. Selena, I'm a huge fan. That's kind of a bit of a meat cue. No, I'm very excited. I like what. Like what. With you, so. Me too. And I grew up. No, I'm very I'm very excited. I like
class with you. So me too. And I grab now 53, 53. All right. So we do or we're we're galloping along with with acting. We've got the Barney under our belts. We'll move into Waverly place. Yes, my Disney show. Yes. And and a few other jobs here and in there and things are really moving and cooking. Yeah. And then there's a cooking show later, we're going to get to that. But when did music start to start to tap you on the shoulder and say, hey, come this way?
Well, I think that Disney is safe to say they're a machine and they kind of, in a way, not forcefully required that I know how to sing so I could seem like the theme song like they know how to package someone and like make it of like a whole triple threat thing. This was happening during Waverly? Yeah so they asked me to do the theme song and I had fun with that and then they were like, would you like to do an album? And I thought it would be fun and I thought more than anything it would be like a hobby that I really enjoyed and then I wanted to be a serious actress. I was 15. And I wanted to be an actress. I'd never really intended on being a singer full time, but apparently that hobby turned into
something else. Yeah, you're doing all right. Now, did you do have any idea that you could sing before you tried it? Yeah, well, I was on Barney, and I do I love you. You love me. Well, that's not very challenging. And you know, it warmed up my vocals.
Okay, all right. There you go. And then because of that, did you take like singing lessons and and develop your instrument, as they say? You know, I did. I don't think I'm the best singer, but I think I know how to tell stories. And I love being able to make songs that, you know, I get more like a, I always get people coming up to me saying, I had no idea it was you that was singing that song and that kind of makes it feel nice to me that I feel like it's just about the song. I mean withers of Waverly Place was a gigantic show. Yeah I miss it. You do. I want to say my sister wrote on that for a second. Really? She was a writer on that maybe. I might not be right. But it was it was a blast like I will say.
Yes that's why I love sitcom. Would you say you have a good memory, Jason? No, not really. Okay. Wayne, we're going to get right back to you but Salina, I want to the so what is it? It's will. Thank you Scott. So, guys the bits. I love the bass. I love it. We'll be right back. Hey, smartless listener, it's Sean.
And I've got to share this scoop on something I'm really vibing with lately. Viori. It's not just workout gear. It's a whole new perspective on performance apparel. Imagine gear that's so versatile you can rock it for workouts, yoga, or just kicking it back on the weekend. I know you've heard me talk about it a million times, but I love it. Now, let's talk comfort. Viori is seriously in a league of its own. I'm telling you, right now I have on the core jogger, I love it, I sleep in it, don't tell Scotty.
And I always wear the Strato Tech T's. I love them. They're so soft and comfortable. I'm not like, you know, they're not clinging to my body. I love it. I could sleep in them and I do, and I go to the store and I do. Ready for the good stuff? Viori is an investment in your happiness and they're hooking up smart list listeners
with 20% off your first purchase at Viori.com slash smart list. That's VU-ORI.com slash smart list. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping and any U.S. orders from $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash smart list and discover US orders from $75 and free returns. Go to viewori.com slash smartless and discover the versatility of viewori clothing. Hey smartless listener, we are supported by Mint Mobile. On average, it takes about 30 days
for a person to break their New Year's resolution. So if saving money was on your 2024 list, your odds aren't looking that great. Luckily, I have 100% guaranteed way to save you money this year. Just switch to Mint Mobile. For a limited time, wireless plans from Mint Mobile are $15 a month when you purchase a three-month plan that's unlimited talk, text, and data for $15 a month. Mint Mobile is here to rescue you with premium wireless plans for just $15 a month.
Say, bye-bye to your overpriced wireless plans, jaw-dropping monthly bills, and unexpected overages. All plans come with unlimited talk and text, plus high-speed data delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. Use your own phone with any Mint Mobile plan and bring your phone number along with all your existing contacts.
Ditch overpriced wireless with Mint Mobile's limited time deal and get premium wireless service for just 15 bucks a month. To get this new customer offer and your new three-month unlimited wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month, go to MintMobile.com slash Smartless. That's MintMobile.com slash Smartless. Cut your wireless build of 15 bucks a month and show your support for the show at MintMobile.com slash Smartless.
Additional taxes fees and restrictions apply cement mobile for details. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So you guys knew you're right, 2024. You're thinking about resolutions. What could I do to improve myself? How could I do better? And then what happens is if you're like me, sometimes you write those resolutions and you focus on those and you hyper focus on those so that you overdo it, so then you fall out of it, whatever it's like eating better or exercising, or whatever the thing is, so you need to pull back and find balance so that you don't overdo it or don't do it at all.
Like, the hardest part is trying to find the balance, right, in the middle, and that's what therapy can do for you. It's done it for me and really, really help me focus and find balance so that I don't overdo it one way or the other. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule.
Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Celebrate the progress you've already made because at BetterHelp.com slash smartless today, to get 10% off your first month, that's betterhelp.hlp.com slash smartless. And now back to the show.
All right, so then you know that you can kind of sing a little bit and the music starts to take off. Like, I guess what I'm asking is what at what point was the acting and the music at the same level and you thought, do I have to pick or should I try to keep both these things up? at what point was the acting and the music at the same level? And you thought, do I have to pick? Or should I try to keep both these things going at the same speed?
I started having a lot of fun with music and then touring was really fun. But I was doing my TV show at the same time. And it wasards and I just, I found it really fun. So I just kept going, but the older I get, the more I'm kind of like, I would like to find something to just settle on. Yeah, well, it's exhausting, right?
I mean, that sounds like super, that's so hard. I just think about the energy of this such an old thing. Oh my God, I went to a mental institute and canceled one of my doors. Really? Yeah. Because it was so exhausting.
Yeah, it just got to me, because I love working, and it distracts me from bad things. And I like that. So I just like working. I was just saying that this morning. By the way, it reminds me my three-year-old Denny. He calls Lizards, because he can't say Ellie calls him Wizards. So he's like, we just me my three-year-old Danny. He calls Lizards because he can't see Ellie calls him Wizards. So he's like, there's a wizard in the backyard. I really
hope there's a wizard in the back room. I'm talking in. But Selena, you're saying that in a perfect world, you would pick either one or the other going forward. Well, I do feel like I have one more album in me, but I would probably choose acting. You would. Yes. God damn you're so great at music though. Yeah, I mean, here's the good news. You don't have to pick. Don't have to pick. You're right, but I am gonna want to chill because I'm tired. But yeah, I mean, reading through, I can tell you, we've had some very accomplished people on this show.
Thank you listeners for making it a place where accomplished people want to come. I have never read so much information about a guest than I have about you. I mean, the things you have done in your, I mean, you're just barely 30, aren't you? 31. 31. It's just so admirable what you've done. It's a mind-on-line. It's a mind-on-line.
It's a mind-on-line. In philanthropy and in global sort of charities and being in what a uniceph ambassador. So, the uniceph ambassador. And now I have my own foundation. It's just stunning. And we haven't even gotten to Rare Beauty, this beauty company, the makeup company. What do you call it? Rare Beauty.
Yeah, but I mean, what would you describe it as a beauty company? I would say cosmetics. You know, it's been really fun, but we're actually starting to get into skin now. I know this is all girly stuff, but I I'm excited. I'm wearing makeup right now. Yeah, exactly. I know, but but we're going into skin now. It's about three years old and it's honestly been the biggest gift because I launched it during COVID and it just took off and I couldn't be more thankful. So did you launch it during COVID because you had time to finally,
because you weren't on tour and you weren't shooting, you're like, now I have time to dedicate to this or landing, can you come up or is it some of you always? It sucked. I was supposed to release it like a month right into COVID. So I had done all the promotion and everything. It's about to come out and then we figured,
all right, we'll just try online. And I think makeup became really big during COVID because people would do the videos and they would create looks and it kind of just took off. And I'm always like confused and just grateful because I've never been the type of person that want. I don't want to be or need to be the number one anything. And I think that's what my mom has instilled in me,
because I don't feel like anything is a competition. So I feel like there's room for everyone. Everybody, yeah. I'm really proud. Do you think like it's, when you started Barney at seven and then Wizards and then all that, do you think that your work ethic and your drive and your ambition was instilled in you or would have happened to anyway?
Oh, I don't know. I'm probably would have been a hot mess if I wasn't doing a mess already. But I don't know. I don't know. I mean, obviously tell us. Obviously tell us how. I mean, oh obviously tell us. I mean, we obviously tell us how. Oh, I've been to like four treatment centers.
Just because of depression and anxiety, right? Yeah, yeah. And I'm bipolar as well. Well, you've got. Carry on top. And I would say you've got an incredible dynamic head on your shoulders that takes a lot of management and
An analysis and it sounds like you're doing a pretty frickin good job Yeah, thank you. Thank you. I don't know Disney was like boot camp, you know, they were definitely Problems, you know doesn't have problem slena dummies I mean, it true. I mean, that's true. It's a blissful ignorance. That's where it comes from You need to be really smart to be complicated. Yeah, and I'm pretty, I don't know. I can be like, I think you're doing great. It's not getting in your way of your accomplishments. And you and I have talked a few times,
you're incredibly nice. So your personal success is fantastic as well, as opposed to your business success. So whatever you're doing, keep going. You're appreciate it. Are you super tight? So your mom, as you said, your mom is or was an actress and kind of that sort of paved the way for you to get into it and take it seriously.
And you mentioned your not only child, imagine you're pretty still pretty close with your folks. to how to imagine you're still pretty close with your folks. Yes. And was that like, when you started to make that transition into becoming a star at a really young age, what was that dynamic like with your folks? Like how much did you rely on them to kind of be there? And how has that relationship changed as you've gotten older?
I mean, do you notice? Yeah, I think when I was younger, my mom, I mean, my mom was my mom, I was under 18. So I was getting invited to these events and stuff. And my mom, from a very early age, was like, you're going to walk the carpet, maybe we'll stay for five minutes, but then adult times are probably going to happen.
And it was like the vanity fair parties and all that stuff. Right. So she was always very protective of me, but it never really felt like it was suffocating. And she would always say the same thing to me. She said, the moment you stop having fun, stop. It's okay. You know, like you, you don't need to just kill yourself over, you know, something. Yeah, because of the hour. Right. And the hours of people don't understand that the hours and hours and hours of work that it takes to do a TV show, a tour, whatever it is, or a movie.
It's just like for a- It's hard enough to be a kid. I just think about it my own kids and being young teenagers, my older boys and I'm just thinking about it. And the younger ones with the speech problems. Right. I was looking for wizards. Wizards.
It's like the idea of them, like Sean, we were over there watching the movie the other night with Archie. Can you imagine Archie's 15 being on the road and working all the time? I think like, no, he wouldn't be able to, he wouldn't be happy. He was about Selena saying,
oh, he had tough, right? Yeah, no, it is. And the transition honestly happened around 25 where I didn't feel like I had to impress my parents more so. But my mom was also really cool because right after Disney she put me in a movie called Spring Breakers. Like she found that movie and it's very, very, very fun.
Yeah. Very, very sweet. Very. But it was fun. Yeah, and it was it. I mean, I'm sure your mom was not strategic with grabbing that nor were you. But I'm sure that there was some thought put into it where this would sort of broaden the public's idea about that which you can do and that which is fitting of when they think about you, she can do this, she can do that. And or was it just a part of like, well this is a little bit closer to who she's starting to become, not somebody who's... My mom was a huge harmony current fan and she heard there was a script out and so she was interested in it and the character I play is an as-ray see.
So I was like 19 when I did it. And she just came up to me and she was this will make no sense. And you're probably gonna think I'm crazy, but just read this. And I read it and I don't know. I gravitated towards the character. And then I met Harmony and I was like, oh, game over. He's just really cool.
How did your mom have the sense to know good material from bad material or the right material? She's really great at that stuff. She found the book 13 Reasons Why, which we turned into a TV show. So she randomly was at a bookstore and she was in young adult and found that and we developed it.
She just has really nice taste, you know. And instincts, clearly. It's, yeah, she's really great. So I like to ask her advice on things. That's great, awesome. Yeah, I love that you guys are so close. Yes. You know, we can cut this part too,
but I am fascinated and thankful for how, I've spoken to you about mental health. Because I have somebody very, very close to me who I've had to deal with it and not deal with it, but just like help with it. Yes. And, but do you, you say thank you to him. You've never publicly thanked him.
No, I was going to say the same thing. All jokes aside, Jason, you dick. I was going to say, oh, no, JK, I was going to say, I like the way, I like the way that you're so open and frank about that, about mental health. And I think that it's something that people, luckily, talk about more and more, but I think it's really refreshing to hear you talk about it in a way that's very, just sort of matter of fact in, and I think it's really, I don't know, it shows real maturity and it shows, I think it's very brave. And I think it helps so many people
the way that you talk, honestly, in that way. I really did struck me. I think it's really remarkable. It is, it's great. Because my mom died of Alzheimer's a long time ago. I forget when, and because of his injuries over. Because it was so painful. Because it was so painful, I just, me and my sister and my family,
we would... There's a point where you have to start making it funny. Yeah. Because you've cried too much about it. So then you cut it with humor. And the funniest, you know, Alzheimer's story is like ever. Because I lived through it.
And it was so tragic that, you know, my mom... We can cut this too. But my mom would go to the bathroom, she'd go number two in the toilet, and I'd walk in there, I'd go, mom, you have to flush the toilet, she goes, I don't know who did that, I don't know who that is, they came in here and I was here, they went to the bathroom. No, we could not prove that that's mine. We could not prove that that's mine. And we would laugh because it was past the point. So my question is, have you, me dealing with somebody with my girlfriend? I'm not proved that that's my, and we would laugh because it was past the point.
So my question is, have you, uh, me dealing with somebody with that? Have I taken a shit and forgot? No, no, no, have you ever, no, have you ever, like, I've ever just kind of infused humor into the whole situation. Definitely. Um, I also have a few friends that are, you know, in comedy and writers and it's it's just fun, you know, and now me and my family are in a place where we can do that. And I don't mind saying the things that I'm walking through and they can be fun and they can be messy.
But I've always- Did you take the power back? Yeah, I just out knowing, but I've always. They take the power back. Yeah, I just know more. I feel better. And it gives so many people, myself included, a little bit more comfort in the reality that I'm not, you know, I'm kind of broken upstairs. We all are.
There are as many mental variables in all of us as there are physical ones. You can see the physical ones. Someone's taller, someone shorter, someone's thicker, someone's thinner, someone's got bigger feet smaller feet. Like, there are their equal number of variables in the brain and the fact that we've got medicine, therapeutics, an environment that is tolerant of all of those variables nowadays, as opposed to back when our parents were our age. Is that right?
And Jason, on top of that community, the idea that you're talking about it, Shedselite says, you're not alone, there's somebody else, and somebody else can relate to that and identify with it. Certainly, I know for my own life, and I can go, like, and somebody else says, I have this and they go, oh, and they talk about their experience and I go,
oh, you have this too. And then we can talk about it in a way that, and that kind of really breaks it wide open. It definitely, it connects you as well. I mean, that's why I released my documentary. It's all based on mental health. Which was incredible. Yeah, I haven't seen it.
I'm so, forget me. No, I, it's, no, pause rate. We're gonna watch it. I'm, no, me. I'm gonna watch that. No, I want to see it. No pause rate. We're gonna watch it. I'm gonna get on here. But it ends well. I just, I think that's why I did the documentary. I was terrified before it came out.
And I had already signed a contract. And I was like, damn, I can't go back. But that was a really big moment for me. And then I had people coming up to me not saying like, oh my god, can I have a picture? They would say I've dealt with depression or I've done this and then I end up having a connection with people. Yeah, I love that. Sometimes with all my health stuff like I've had a kidney transplant, I have high blood pressure. I gosh, I have mental, mental health and I don't even know.
I'm sure I have other problems that I'm not aware of. I love talking about all of them. You can think about like a situation and say, why me, why me? And instead, it's given me the gift to say, oh, I know why it's me. I'm there for those people that are going through what I went through. And I can say, I hear you and I see you. Not just be in and say, my life's perfect, what I went through. And I can say I hear you and I see you, not just be in and say my life's perfect, but I'm sorry, you know, it's like,
well, I can be honest with you. I'm a big believer that the person upstairs, or whomever's upstairs for anybody, doesn't give you anything more than what you can handle. Yes. And so the fact that you've been given all of these gifts, challenges, and that you're able to go through them so successfully in a public space, such that you can give encouragement and support and to others is like, I mean, talk about using your years right. We've talked about it on the show before, about when you get to the end,
you're gonna, we're all gonna look back and hope that we used our time correctly. I mean, the first 30 years of your life have been incredibly accomplished. Like 20 lives, mentally, certainly. Yeah, I guess the question really is slated now, what? Yeah. You know, you're fixing your brain,
you're fixing the world. Yeah, I don't know. I think I just, I gravitate towards things I connect to. And I'm all about authenticity. I can't really force myself to be anything than who I am. And it's just, you know, luckily worked. It's about your ability to recognize and attract those who are equally authentic is really keen too.
You know, like I'm just thinking when you're talking about the documentary and thinking about Alec Asixian and his sister, Aline, we both work with. I mean, people like that, like you probably have a great team around you, great friends around you, like all of us as we get older, you have less and less friends, but that's usually by choice. Talk to us about your ability to kind of pick up on people's uniqueness and authenticity
you're lacking thereof. Is that something you always had or has it just gotten sharper? And maybe it has gotten sharper, but ever since I was younger, I like to think I had good discernment with people. And I could just sense when I felt that it was being forced or that there was something they were wanting or whatever, I just could feel that in a lot of people. And I mean, obviously I put some of those people in my life when I was younger,
and then I later realized, but most of my friends, like I said, they're, I mean, they can go from being a writer to one of my friends is a real, one of my friends is a realtor. So, like I kinda... Is that Richard Arleic? I kinda just... It's not Richard Arleic, is it? No.
Yeah, well, it's's having people skills, right? And I wonder if you're like me, that's part of what has always attracted me to being an actor is because I'm just fascinated with people. And I really enjoy reading people and seeing is this a person a match for me or not? And I just wonder what that is. Also, it's just staying curious, right?
Yeah. The moment you stop being curious, then like Jason just said, you become one of those dummies. Yeah, no, I love life and I love people. And I find it really fun. Do you find that which do you find is more cathartic for you, more sort of a lane to explore and enjoy parts of you, is it with playing different characters or being a songwriter?
I think it's a little bit of both. I wrote this ballad called Luzy to Love Me and that was probably the most personal song I'd ever released about something that was on everyone's mind for some reason. And then in acting, I feel like I have these moments in my life that have happened and I'm able to use that and it actually feels great. And it feels like after a good cry or something, it's like a good feeling. Is there something that you, I mean, this is going to be one of the dumbest questions you've ever got? Is there something with every single thing that you've done? We're just like, you know what, I've never done. I want to, I
need to do that before. Oh, yeah. I don't think I've even began like in a lot of areas. Like I, not necessarily cosmetics and stuff, but like I've said many times with you guys, I think acting. I don't think I've been able to even touch the surface of what I know that I'm capable of doing. I'm very selective or else I'd be in all of the movies that I get offered. I just fight for my roles and I'm always auditioning, so I like to earn it. Yeah, that's great. We'll be right back. Smartless listener, if you like to laugh, and I hope so,
this year catch two hilarious comedies starring two legendary Johns, John Leraket, in the new season of Nightcourt, and John Cryer in his new comedy Extended Family. Tuesday nights on NBC, the laps are never in short order. When New York's most outrageous court gets back in session, it's America's number one comedy, Night Court, starring John Lerichette.
And after that, catch John Crier in a great new comedy about life and family after divorce, it's Extended Family. Also starring the amazing Donald Fazon and Abigail Spencer. Laugh more in 2024 with two fantastic comedies, Night Court and and extended family, starring John Larraquette and John Cryer,
Tuesday's UnNBC. Hey, Smartless Crew, I've been drinking AG1 since 2020. It's become my daily go-to foundational nutrition supplement. Really, I trust AG1 because it's not just about what's in it, but what's not, catch my drift. AG1 is rigorously tested for 950 impurities way beyond the industry norm. Seriously, it's a game changer for me.
I feel the difference daily. What I love about it is it's so easy. You can make it smoothie and just dump it in with all the other stuff in your smoothie or you can just mix it with water and take it on the go. And your body's getting all the vitamins and minerals that you could possibly need. Instead of taking a bunch of supplements and buying all that healthy food that you have to eat,
it's just AG1 all in one drink. Now, let's get into the good stuff. Why AG1? It's a powerhouse for major body systems with ingredients like vitamin C and zinc, which helps me make my immune health and tip top shape. AG1 is the supplement I trust to provide the support my body needs daily, and that's why they've been a partner for so long. If you take just one thing, let it be AG1. Try AG1 and get a free one-year supply of item in D3K2 and five free AG1 travel packs with your first purchase. Go to drinkag1.com slash smartless
so they know we set you. That's drinkag1.com slash smartless, check it out. Thank you, Stitch Fix for supporting this episode. Hey, are you still clinging to the same old jeans and hoodies from Fall? If you're ready to level up your winter wardrobe, but the uncertainty of sizing it online shops has you feeling lost, a Stitch Fix stylist can help you with a new winter wardrobe tailored just for you. Stitch Fix is an easy way to get clothes that fit you without having to endlessly browse through options
or break the bank. Think of them as your style partner. Your stylist will learn about your taste and collaborate with you on looks you love. With your choices in mind and a wide range of sizes available from XS to three XL, they'll find your perfect fit and send you clothes hand-picked just for you. They have over 1,000 brands and styles
and do the work of choosing the best options for you. They'll even show you how to wear head to toe outfits so you can just get dressed and go. And if you don't love something, just send it back. Shipping returns and exchanges are always free. You know, look, you can always go online and just click and order clothes, but how cool is it to get a personal stylist
to help you come up with ideas and put clothes together because I'm horrible at it. I used to work at a retail company and I would put clothes together all the time and none of it matched for customers. And now I get this, this is so great. I wish I had this to help me. Thanks StitchFix, they just get me
and they'll get you too. Try today at StitchFix.com slash SmartLess and you'll get 25% off when you keep everything in your fix, that StitchFix.com slash SmartLess. StitchFix.com slash SmartLess. slash smartless stitchfix.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. Something I've sort of really gotten more and more passionate about is not playing characters as much as just playing
somebody that doesn't force me to do a lot of acting and play a character, I kind of like to be the audience. And a lot of that comes from my desire to try to be as not full of shit as possible in my life and not be fake and funny and pretending to be other people. So I really like trying to be as authentic as I can. Do you have a similar sort of battle when you think about acting because you're so good about being really you and being in your skin and being honest, it does that run counter to the whole thing
that we try to do as actors? Kind of, but I just finished this movie, this Jacques Radeard film and it's all in Spanish and it's a musical and it was one of the most challenging things that I've done. But it's really, Emilia Perez, I think that will come out next year. It's so good if you just said none of your business. I'm excited for that because for example there's the scene where I'm being left and I'm not giving anything away and I remember I channeled the moment when I had to go to rehab for the first time and leaving and I I remember I told my co-star
That's what I was feeling in the moment and I just felt like it was getting that out when I remembered that first moment and being terrified. That's cool. So it felt really cathartic. Speaking of that, have you ever wanted to go to, you know what I'm gonna ask, go to the Broadway or do live theater? Or maybe you have.
I haven't. I think I would like to. I'm not sure I'm there yet, because I think I'd still be a little nervous. Oh, really? Yeah. After touring, you've'd still be a little nervous. Oh, really? Yeah. After touring, you've already been like a stage performer. No, but it's different, because I love when I'm doing my concert, because it's like,
oh, these are my peeps. Right, right, right. You feel comfortable. You feel safer, yeah, yeah, for sure. Well, will you talk more about that, about battling, because I get very nervous when I have to speak publicly like I can't even give a toast. Really? Yeah, he goes white.
That's true. Yeah, but I have an enormous amount of confidence when it comes to other things that are going to be made for the public. A million kinds of camera. From millions of people as opposed to 10 people at a dinner table. So I don't understand that about myself, the difference between having a lot of confidence or zero confidence that are sort of similar things. How are you doing?
Because you're so well spoken in life, just, I mean, clearly in life, that's why I blows my mind that anytime where like a dinner party was, or like two, three years ago, we are at your birthday dinner party at Richard's house. Yeah. And I said, let's go around the room and say, how grateful, how much we love Jason, and I'll start, and I got up, and I gave this little speech,
and it got to, and you were like, I'm out. I don't want any part of this. It's like tonight. Yeah. But yeah, so how do you manage that? Like, what is that switch that flicks for you It's like good-bye. But yeah, so how do you manage that? Like what is that switch that flicks for you when you can stand up in front of, you know, a hundred thousand people and give a concert or do a movie or a television show that's going
to be from millions of people versus like maybe going out on a date for the first time or doing an interview for a magazine or whatever might give you anxiety, do you know what that is, that different thing? Because I'm still trying to figure it out with myself. Well, I think when I was younger, I had a very, very public life and it wasn't fair in a lot of ways that I got to the point so much so that I was like, if I don't talk about what's going on, everyone's going to continue to narrate my life and people are just going to buy it. And I need people to hear from me. And I genuinely stopped caring.
Like, I don't, I don't care. Like, I would be happy to stand up and speak very highly of someone. I'd be happy to do it. Even if I mess up, I'm like, all right, well, that sucked. But, you know, I tried. I'm like, it's fine. So I don't know if I'm just, I've done it for too long, but I just have lost a little bit of that fear. But I still get the butterfly feeling.
Yeah. So maybe I just got used to it, and then I'm kinda like, oh, people are gonna like it or not. Yeah, I have a friend of mine, Maria Shriver. She, you know, I've known her for years and years and decades. And she, whenever I would have dinner at her house, she's the one who forced me to get up and talk like that. And it's so, I was littered, you know,
sorry, I was riddled with fear about it. And, but she forced me to do it. She's like, we're gonna go around and stand up and speak how you feel. And I was like, pass. I'm going to the next part. Were you so nervous that you would just littered?
Is that what you're saying? I'm like, I'm having a tough time following what happened. But Jay, Marie, okay. But now that you're saying it, I think like for me, it's like I'm afraid of being accused or judged as either being full of shit or being stuck up. I think I had a real complex about being conceited and stuck up when I was in middle school.
Like, 67th grade was really hard for me in school because people, oh, here comes that guy on TV. He stuck up. So I wasn't really, I was shy about being confident because people would think I was stuck up. So then I tried to seem not confident and then maybe that part of me kind of took hold. But what's crazy about that though is think about it.
That's inauthentic. Yeah, exactly. If you think about it, you fell victim of the very thing that you were trying to prevent. I mean, that honestly. And when you're thinking about it that much, you put a space between you and people you're trying to connect with.
Jay, I really mean it. And if you can break that down and react in real time, then it will never be inauthentic. But the second you start thinking about, you're trying to curate what other people think of you, that's inauthentic. Yeah, and that makes me so nervous because I'm having to manage two things
at the very same time. Right, right, because you're taking care of their feelings before yours. Yeah, you're never gonna be able to before you are. Yeah. Yeah, you're never going to be able to, I remember somebody saying, you can't tell everybody how to treat you or how to look at you. There's nothing you can do about the way people think about you. Yeah, you can do stuff.
You can do stuff. Well, yeah, there's that and also like, you'll never, you'll never get to. Celina, one second. Yeah. Yeah. No, it's okay. I'm enjoying this.
I like that conversation. But really, just really quick, it's the same thing that I've cared around for so long being gay is like, I've caught my entire life. I just came out. My entire life, I've been, I spent taking care of other people's feelings and putting my second. And then you have to reach a point where Salina is saying,
we're like, I can't, I'm exhausted. But why did you do that for other people? With regards to you being gay, is that what you mean? Yeah, yeah, with, like, if I enter a room, even today, I still have a little bit leftover, but for the most part, I don't care. It's like, I have to check, like, I'm so used to, it's in my blood now to check how people think about me entering a room. Are they thinking about my really being here or not?
No way. I used to do this when I was younger. I remember I was doing an interview and I sat down and there was probably 14 people behind the camera. And I was, I think it was maybe 21. And I started to sweat and I ran away and I started crying. Because this is what I was thinking. I was like, these people probably think I sound stupid. They're going to go home and tell their partners or friends about how much of an idiot I am. And I feel like a horrible interviewer. I just, it used to kill me.
Yes, with panic attack. Yeah, I've had that and I couldn't, I couldn't, I was stuck there and it just becomes exponentially more horrific and terrifying because now you're convinced, now they can see that I'm having a panic attack. Now it gets even worse. So it's like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It is so, so we have that too, huh? I mean, I still fall back into it, but I've, you know, here and there, but for the most part, I'm like, I really mean this. I'm sure there'll be a lot of listeners like, should the fuckable you know, I really, this is new to me. I don't understand it in that way. I just some everybody's wired difference. I form a parent like when I like when I got this, you know,
when I got this you know when I got this Holding up and I was sort of just plain white and I and I faceless body I thought I can thank you everybody But I feel like the older I get the closer I get to our favorite term sexy indifference or or rather better better said a healthy indifference. Where you do care what people think, but you're not, you're not obsessed by it and you're not, you're not pulled around. I will challenge you on that because we're doing it right now today. That is also put on.
It's not real because if you have to think about the sexy indifference, then it's not organic. Right. No, no, I'm trying to get to that place of, of, of honest and healthy indifference, that it's not organic. Right. No, no, I'm trying to get to that place of honest and healthy indifference where it's just right-sized. You know, where you do care about people, you don't want to be rude, you want to be sensitive if you're going to see the whole another. You just want to see the other. The freedom is when you don't even have to recognize that you do have indifference,
that you're just living. That's the freedom. You're otherwise, you're shackled by the idea of it. It still lives there as an idea. But it's also what we do for a living, right? It's part of our job to be aware of what people think and kind of manipulate that. And like, that's professional liars. And so it was a little bit of a headscrew for me, obviously, still is when I was a kid,
when you're trying to figure out who you are and who you're becoming. I can't imagine as a kid. You're training yourself how to fake to be somebody else. It's kind of a little bit more interesting. Do you still think about that Selena? Absolutely. I remember I was talking about this with someone and there was a study that said, the moment you get famous at a certain age, you end up stuck in that area for a while because it stunts your, yes, because it stunts your, your, your dealing with things that no child should be dealing with and criticizing my body or something weird. Like it just, it felt,
just, it doesn't feel good. You can't grow privately, like most people do. You know, that. Yeah, so I mean, I don't regret my life, but there's a huge part of me that's like, yeah, I wonder what that would have been like to just be me for a second. So, but this, I'm assuming that, you know,
you've got millions, literally millions of people that admire you more than any of us could probably imagine because of how brave you are, with how honest you are. And that is not going to go away, thank God. I mean, you're a role model, whether you like it or not. Till I run away from everything. No, no, you're not role model, whether you like it or not. Till I run away from everything. No, no, you're not gonna go wherever you go,
you're gonna be there. No, don't take away her out until you run away. If you will. I rode away. But, but I now get it though, Jay, I wanna say, because you just mentioned that, I wanna say that I now get it when I sort of earlier, flippantly when we first started talking about
how many millions of followers you have, I now understand, I get it now, your relationship with that number, with those numbers of people is tricky. And I sort of have a little bit more of an understanding. I really mean that, maybe I'm a slow learner. No, no, it's weird. It's such a bizarre thing. And they give you way too much information. Like they'll they'll tell you how many accounts you'd reached
and they'll tell you the percentages of women versus male or or button non-variant or whatever it is. It's like I don't need this information. I just want to post a photo and let it be for my fans and move on. And they are definitely attracted to all the things that are very special about you and not to take away from any of that. But I think it is also very indicative of how common it is
for people around the world to be not perfect. And I think they really are comforted by how you are so honest about how not perfect you are. And I think that's just a real gift that you give to people and myself included. I thank you for that. I cannot believe we're already past an hour. But literally the fastest interview. Yeah, I'm stunned. Not an hour. Yeah, but literally the fastest interview. Yeah, I'm stunned. Not an hour right now, but it is pretty crazy. Yeah.
I'm like, right? I'm like, right? I want to punch. Yeah. I want to let you go, but I know we have probably a couple of more questions. Sure, and go. Yes, no, I just want to know only murderers.
I love the show. I love you in it. I love Stephen Marty. How did it come about? What was it like when you started? Did you just love murderers? How you got in? To be honest, yes. And I like very dark documentaries sometimes. So I tend to like lean into those especially scary stuff mentally. And John Hoffman is one of my very good. So but no, it actually happened because,
well, Steve's original idea was that it was going to be three men. And then John Hoffman suggested that they hired, yes, who created the show. He said, I think it would be really cool if we added like a younger character, maybe a female. And Steve liked the idea. And I guess this was really a gift
because they had me in mind. And I remember thinking, I'm like, okay, well, what does this mean? And then I had FaceTime with all of them. I went Steve, Marty and John and producers, and I was like, oh, I just have to do this because simply the people are amazing. And then success of it after. It's a good hang. Yeah. And then the success after was just such a, like, surprise and we just were happy to do it.
That only murders in the building. Never man slutters. Never man slutters. Never man slutters. Okay. Okay. I'm fine. I'm allowed to ask. Yes, you are. And that is in its fourth year or fifth year coming up on the
fifth. We just got renewed for season four season four. And I may we may have to cut this, but John asked John. I was like, how how many more seasons? And he goes, why ask Steve? And Steve said forever. I know he does. My favorite thing about Steve and he knows that I've said this before, but my favorite thing is Steve will be like, I've got to get, I've got to get home. I've got to get home. I've got to go. I'm too old for this. And then I'll be like, that'll be like, well, I go Steve, like how many seasons?
He's like, oh, I don't want to stop. We're going to keep going. And I'm like, yeah, you just have to get home. Exactly. But you need to be home. So sometimes I'll be like, I'll carry the load because it is the greatest trio, but as it has been said before, one of the oddest trios. Yeah. And it's so awesome. Yeah. Awesome. Yeah. Awesome. Yeah. Great. Well, Selena, this has been great. Thank you, honey, for being here. Of course, I just wanted to tell you, Jason, really quick. Yes, ma'am.
I am going to send your wife Amanda and your girls some of my new collection from Rare Beauty. And like a whole little box because I would love to see, you know, what they thought or I love. There are enormous fans of yours as is Amanda, my wife. Yay. So I can, I want to send you that because this is going to be, this is going to be one of the biggest collections that I've released and I'm beyond stoked for it. I know it's, it's little things like that that make me happy because.
Yeah, but it's, it's not a little thing. It's really impressive what you've done with this. It's this company is potentially, if it's not already bigger than anything you've done in music or in film or television or in social media. I mean, it's an enormous company and you really should be proud of that.
But I think it's good products and we also just try not to be everything else. You know, like I'm not huge on promoting like crazy, you know, makeup. I love makeup, but I want my line to represent yourself and to have fun with it. And it seems very consistent with you and what you represent. Well, my, I share your skin as long flawless. Oh, my, a nice bowl. Thank you. Uh-huh.
That's you. She takes out her glasses. She goes cross side. She did a rich and early. Oh, yeah. What does it say? It's where? It's a little bit confused.
And then that could look at that beautiful. So she let her say it's where? Say it. Ready and action. No, where? I swear. Oh, my God, that's good. That's really good.
You look just like Richard Herlock. Great. Selene, you're the greatest. I think I so much for doing this. This is a big, big get for us. It's so awesome to be able to. I am so happy and hopefully I'll get to meet you all in person. I'm sure I'll run into you, Jason.
I'm just, I'm a big fan of all of you. And I've really been wanting to do this for a while. I'm run into you, Jason. I'm just my big fan of all of you, and I've really been wanting to do this for a while. I'm sure you know, Jason. So this has been really great. Thank you. Yeah, for doing you. All right. Have a great, great rest of the day.
And thanks for talking with us. Yeah. Bye, guys. All right. Bye, Selena. Thank you. You see, now, guys, there's a nice person. You guys have asked me multiple times.
You say, you say, you say, Jason, how do I get, how can I become nice? How can I become nicer, you know, and be pleasant? Have success, right? Isn't that you're a theory? You do have success, but then after that, you did try to be not before. Not before, because then they're going to be accused
of trying to and is gentle as loving as you know, okay? What is that? Will's holding up a fake award. This is my dressing room. I don't know. It's just something like and it looks like an award. It does. It looks like an ask.
I, um, yeah, she's really true. Yeah, no, she's what did you both? Did you learn anything you guys? I did. I feel like I'm lazy. Yeah. I think. Well, a lazy because she's just did you both, did you learn anything you guys? I did. I feel like I'm lazy. Yeah. I think. Well, a lazy because she's just so it seems like everything she does, she's successful
at even even mental health. Right. She's successful at that. Right. Right. Because she's not running from it. She's going right through it. She's just.
It's it's pretty remarkable. And she's so she's such, talk about we were talking authenticity was a central trend today. And she's so authentic. She's like, I'm just a superhero. Really doesn't, like she said, she just does what she loves to do. Everybody's welcome to come or don't come.
Like, you know, it's funny. I was gonna say, she said that she didn't care, but it's almost like she, it's not that she doesn't care. It feels like she just, what she cares about is just being herself and being. Yeah. And what she turned that care internal, she's taking care of number one, which for me,
always lets me be a better person to the people around me. Sometimes I over index in the selfishness, but I'm trying to get the right balance. Yeah. Yeah. No, sorry. No. Still rolling. I'm trying to get the right balance. Yeah. Yeah. No, sorry. No. Still rolling.
Let's get one more of those. Well, a little more convincing. Oh, no, Jason. I was, I held up on so many because it was such such, so many things I wanted to throw in and I didn't because it was just at a respect. It's so nice. Oh, so you've got some unused jokes you'd like to more chop up real quick? No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, to work out real quick. No, no, no, no, no, no, there's one at the end certainly that I wanted. Yeah, let's hear it.
Don't worry, I'll carry the load Steve. And I was like, Sean, how many time? Okay. So, do you want to know, right? Steve, right? Steve, right. Do you want to know though? I, speaking about Archie, your son.
Oh, here we go. He's, this is my. No, this is why. Outside, once I had a wizard crawl at my pants. Now, was it really? Did you really? Yeah, truly, it crawled. It crawled a wizard crawl there.
And how hard did it get up before it pulled a quick 180 and said, no, thank you. Now, that's such a funny thing wizard. You can do this for so many things. Oh, you know what? Okay. So part of my, part of my, what is he called? The Gay Tray?
That Jason called it? Oh, yeah, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, sorry. It's a gay tray, it's an invisalign thing. Yeah. I didn't know you had it in today. Yeah. So I have it in all everyday and then but I can whiten my teeth. But my dentist on three days ago
said you care some teeth whitening stuff you could put in the in business line trays. And but you you don't have to put them in the back where the by My Cuspids are by Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarv, and Bennett Barberco. If you like Smart List, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wundry Plus in the Wundry app or on Apple Podcasts.
Prime members can listen to add free on Amazon music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. There is nothing more joyous than the holidays. Joyous! Did you say joyous? There is nothing joyous about Christmas. Anyways, I have such great memories with my family decorating, listening to holiday music
and watching Christmas movies. Sounds like a lot of noise, noise, noise to me. Oh, hey, well, he's already interrupted my interest, so I guess I can reveal our next guest. The Grinch, anything you want to tell our listeners? Well, yes, actually, I have a new podcast. From Wondery, Tis the Grinch Holiday talk show is a pathetic attempt by the people of O'Vill to use my situation as a teachable moment. So join me, the Grinch!
Listen as I launch a campaign against Christmas cheer, grilling celebrity guests, like chestnuts on an open fire. Your family will love the show! As you know, I'm famously great with kids. Follow Tis the Grinch Holiday Talk Show on the Wondering app or wherever you get your podcasts. you know, I'm famously great with kids. Follow Tiz the Grand Choliday Talk Show on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.